thing you do you guys think we should
start a band oh my god yes me you and
Andy yeah
that's it sway in the morning shake for
five eight minutes past the top and
Alison since I've been saying all day is
Thursday which is Friday even I booked
this way in the morning and every single
Thursday we do first day with Kelly okay
we've got something today we have a New
York Times bestseller three times the
sun-earth well here's the good news
there's a lot of places where you are
needed
you're needed for universe the foremost
you're needed to yourself you know
that's what but that's a real thing if I
had to explain this gift the one word
would be dynamic yeah I appreciate you
know hey Gera somebody just texted me
somebody just Instagram message me hey
Gary so Mark Zuckerberg right has
Facebook live 170,000 strong no hiccups
you had 2,000 crashed all the time you
bring them enough money you should say
something I'm gonna text sex right now
there we go yeah what the [ __ ] you're
like the first facebook clothes you have
on your face is so funny the first
Facebook page post
oh yeah like on my page yeah well her
day wanted like you sucks and Kevin
seriously yeah that's cool and like PS
use that will really oh the black and
green when I was in Kuwait
yeah so Gordon funny what no I'm just
yo Andy why'd you call my original
Facebook post corny just now tell
everybody is there corny first this
fired versus this yeah but I mention
those corney's got more reach cuz that
normally got 9,000 that's what I'd
rather be corny and winning than fly and
losing directed one of those do one of
those cards right here do that thing you
did do that thing you do that thing you
do is such a good movie
Oh
I love that goddamn movin up doing that
thing you do I know but what's a lot and
tried to get you any good sale of it
thing you do we call ourselves age
Andy Gary hit Emily will be huge guys I
have a shitload of SoundCloud followers
morning Kanye yeah so crazy mother hey
Tracy yo one of my top five favorite
human oh my gosh thank you good it's so
good seeing you in the flesh thank you
you record what I've like thought about
you all this time like a freaking
holiday and good vibes a good mom nice
to meet you how are you yeah I want to
advance copy of your book and I have my
desk
okay she's like you know Gary was like
oh my god was it yes I was like carry on
sweet show no my peripheral vision is so
strong so I'm walking to do and I was
like oh my god yeah I had no idea that
yeah yeah it's awesome
linked for life and I love it I love it
I have so many questions so I'm not
going to be quiet now so when you get on
the air but it's such perfect timing
because the girls other day opened up
their conversation was people who have
started businesses and they didn't work
how did you transition what did you do
next yeah we're we're innovating our
studio so no one makes shifts to I'm not
I'm not fancy
oh that Gary Vee hey guys doing real
pleasure
how you doing passing that book out you
know the askgaryvee the questions the
answers in our book in the MLM build an
organization work with value or what
benefit are we gonna have from having
that book so I think anybody in any
business is gonna get to see what are
the difference so I talked a lot about
self-awareness I talk a lot about
empathy I talk a lot about gratitude I
talk about work-life balance I talk
about parenting so there's a lot of
tactics elite in there what you should
do on facebook twitter periscope
Instagram snapchat but then on top of it
it's really that higher-level thinking
okay not only or here's how you can do
it why are you doing it what are other
ways to do it it's just a much deeper
thought because it's like three four
hundred questions and answers it's super
tactical of both the tactics and the
religion right it's like here's the
religion and here go to church on Sunday
got it it's both right citizens you
listening to Gary Vaynerchuk love it
time to be a part of my snapchat show I
want to be as mistress some days I want
to be as adopted child I love it every
day that I'll take all thanks so much
welcome thank you thank you thank you
guys take care l LA you are en thank you
so much
Sabra literally obviously you sound whoa
it's boo that's right that's right it's
good to see you man oh well good man
yeah just you know everyday watching
your stuff it's literally life-changing
thank you so much brother
I appreciate that beautiful d-roc to the
Iraqis Lynn got it real thank you guys
thank you so much take care of yourself
stay well I'll see you Sunday
Thank You Man I used to come here every
Wednesday night do the show I did an
hour on tech and an hour on wine
you want me to take a look at kind of
like world numbers in and kind of make
some recommendations on what we should
do to check the boxes on some extra
infrastructure which is what I assume
you need with the assistant and where
and what kind of costs we should be
looking at for rent
I see you Bobby ocean I appreciate it
yeah I love you dude thanks for that
[ __ ] good to meet you man nice to meet
you man
what's your name vomit mohammed real
pleasure yeah likewise dude you're an
inspiration
big time thank you bro
awesome man hey baby thanks for saying a
lot yeah likewise you do it dude
thank you bro
it's so humbling it's I will never it
just it's so flattering morning just a
matter of time thank you Andy just a
matter time Marcus hello Court just a
matter of time capturing capturing this
never again good solid handshake this
morning
yawns are you serious you broke your
foot on that play that's the best I'm so
pumped what's the deal with what am I
waiting to set up meeting so ever find
out so what's up hey John good this okay
yeah
like well you can see again good fire
penny fire Kenny I think kids doesn't do
a good job as much as I hate to say you
can produce that [ __ ] 50 rock boy let me
know thank you there you go to
Westchester give me give me give me real
realities say look you know this is what
I can't get in like what are you gonna
cancel and I'm not gonna cancel the
client stuff so it'll be after or not
you know I'm gonna keep setting to you
because if it hacks people cancel think
oh jeez people cancel things but if not
then not come with us yep please really
I would definitely consider anything is
real for is the offer probably higher
unfortunately let's meet you how are you
I'd love to go I don't think I'm gonna
be able I can't do it that day because
I'm like coming from Australia like I'm
going from Australia to Cleveland Ohio
that day so I'm not sure with with it
with a five-hour stop in Holland Oliver
I came to say hello anyway good birthday
brother
thank you are you weird okay I was where
- not that bad actually I was way worse
at 30 yeah
Chubb bird he doing I looked at my
baseball team for the first time in
seven thousand years yesterday I emailed
you told you no I think you're making a
mistake
about what definitely I'm not packing I
have a real team
I got Aaron judge the greatest human
being of Earth who's dropped 50 spots
yeah it's great all right I like at
Steve Carr like copy you anything or do
you just kind of want to go with put a
chapter 1 rant chapter 1 right okay
on the VTA so it's never actually hit
your feet love it we're gonna do that
today okay then we have Jab Jab Jab
right hook article tomorrow
you okay which because thank you yep
she got their sushi time stamp that do
you rock those rare footage the one time
I've eaten lunch on dailyvee took 1
minute we have a meeting right got a
cancel what I did that wasn't what I was
referring to join it but that was very
good work that was very good work on
your part
no no that was tremendous work on your
part you get for meeting tomorrow
good I'm watching man nice it's a good
episode sets the beast bums yeah he's
got something we have a meeting tomorrow
you you and I feel like just us at like
7:00 at 100 early Rick my Friday night
but I'm I'm a Knicks game tomorrow is
that like that's the screen time make
sense
are you gonna come with me to the garden
oh that's my weight my meeting is 6:45
so that's wrong huh you're probably 647
I guess I'm going back to back with you
guys it's amazing what are you guys
doing oh I know you're doing see ya
this guy's leet and I'm like don't know
what to do with my like to me like I
don't know what to do my two minutes of
downtown I'd like two minutes of
downtime I'm like I don't know how it
I'm John here yeah I'm just coming oh I
know you just you just work I just work
away fine this is part this is perfect I
want to make a trade yeah what do you
need everything AJ unloaded it was Cory
well yeah we're a trailer shop Franco
you're loaded with a bunch of mediocre
stuff not really man listen and by way
if anybody would have your assets and
have a chance to win it to you because
you'll go out and flip three-second
rounders for a star when she's naked oh
you like what cuz what is bar seven
second rounders no no no bro I'm talking
about my keepers are to hear my meeting
here what am i open they're here can I
get a coffee please
go1 hello nice I'm just me how are you
son you'd always say Peter how are you
yes I remember then I spoke the other
day you know we have clients there's
some there if you want some you know
they were spending all their money on
Spike TV cuz I'm trying to get to the
younger demo that's young my cable
channel they were spending millions of
dollars in production they made a funny
little spot 30 seconds and they ran it
for a year and you know how you guys do
it and business was down we find you
know they heard my spiel three years
earlier than you we chipped away chipped
away chipped away
we grew which was a very small brand at
$900,000 all in working and non-working
twelve years flat we took it over we did
Pinterest only and a little bit of
Facebook which was unheard of three
years ago Pinterest is still unheard of
by most people yeah and we grew the
business twelve percent because women
are paying attention there we think
would win the fight you were Tyler Tyler
Tamayo
on a serious note who doin come on don't
go back whoa
try to hear that I'm aggressive which I
seldom do yeah everybody says that oh
yeah everybody says that until I get
punched in the face and they cry yeah if
I get really mad well trout why would
you think you would fight Tyler
you'd only fight them if you were in a
really bad mood right like so don't
hedge it
thank you thanks
good afternoon so I'm a whole lot of
time so I figured I would do what I
normally do which is try to reverse
engineer the audience and bring them
value and so the guy bought $117 case of
Pinot Grigio right so $10 a bottle Pinot
Grigio I go in his Twitter account on
this flight and all he's tweeting is the
following Jay Cutler I love you Jay
Cutler you're the best Jay Cutler I'm
mad at you he's a huge for those that
don't know Jay Cutler was is and wasn't
I'm the quarterback of the Chicago Bears
right so he's talking about Jay Cutler
Jay Cutler so I call the call my my
point person back of the story I said
look I want you to go to Ebay and I want
you to buy him a signed Jay Cutler
Jersey which was like $350 much more
than the eight percent profit we made on
the 111 dollar case of Pinot Grigio and
I want you to send a note in there and
say thank you for your order thanks for
shopping Wine Library so great so I send
it and then three and a half weeks go by
and nothing happens and I'm like this
son of a gun is really not going to
acknowledge this random kindness so you
know we sent out some other stuff and
then out of nowhere I'm actually
ironically I'm about to take stage at a
talk in Las Vegas and I get a phone call
from Kristin and she goes I mean she
hasn't called me yet she works in the
thank you Department doesn't really need
me she's only to call me about these
couple of things we sent out and I pick
up the phone I go you got something she
goes kind of like oh go ahead she goes I
want to read you the order we just got
so she reads off this order and how many
people here into wine but great Wow
amazing
so this person orders forty eight
hundred dollars worth of high-end red
burgundy you know Coach dari like do
Jack like real stuff for the real nerds
in here anyway and here's what the
comment box said it said hey my name is
Craig once you know you guys sent my
friend John a Chicago Bears Jersey and
he told me the story and that's how I
found out about ups you have great
prices on red burgundy PSS I'm a huge
Bruce Springsteen fan the punchline of
that story is you guys are curating
events and experiences that really
matter
people today more and more as time goes
on are sharing more and more information
about themselves we can cry about
privacy but every day we prove with our
actions that we don't care right and
really there's a much more fascinating
debate over that which is that people
are inherently good the mainstream media
just talks about the small 1% of that
and that's why we share our privacy your
ability to know a lot more about the
people that are coming to these events
is far greater than you may believe and
that if you actually put the time to
understand who that is I promise you
this that if I came to one of your
events as a top seller or executive and
I walked into my hotel room and instead
of a fruit basket or a bottle of wine or
a nice welcome note that there was a New
York Jets hat that would matter to me
because that would show the thing that
matters more than anything which is
intent and effort thanks for having me
guys yeah have a great night thank you
possibly thank you so much thank you
thank you
good right that sounds good all right
thank you thank you so much thank you so
much thank you
really nice to meet you thanks hey shut
up yeah you too the Watchers felt like
throughout the week good for the past
year now I'm just a small time after I'm
just doing my own thing serious thing
man I'm not like a business owner
necessarily but it translates to
everything yeah go baby so much so it's
like to go
thanks for saying yeah that was you well
good luck here Thanks good luck chance
on that second thank you thank you this
book is gonna be really interesting it's
gonna go very well that's awesome thank
know what we're still pushing all those
sales to the first week but yeah you
announce decide your will change it and
we can see pop another stuff so cool I
know thank you big again
hey there Chuck my name's AG Tran and I
just applied to one of your jobs now I'm
trying something guts you through
snapchat just stay tuned I'm about to
send you a videos new Zak where your
video at your Zak
where's your video at
he gave my wife's water stroke we're
just packing up to head to the hospital
i I just want to say I do that better
not be [ __ ] true because you should
not be snapping me when your wife's
water Briggs but if it's true Mazel Tov
Congrats dude that better not be [ __ ]
it's me and d-roc
always it's me they got to escape what
influences at school naval in LA Oh
getting my whoo
we're out to LA next week two weeks does
that it Dennis knows right Scott - yes
I'll find out right brother
take care
what up gang sorry I'm late father
chocolate looks so good Oh cupcakes God
but guess what thing again
no yes so I'm in 2013 we only use 23 of
blenders again you're really focus and
the people that we've done it know we
get we know we got we got it that's the
prorated math had you stayed that exact
course I don't even know what the
availab ones this question
Carrie based on your approach to this
book what do you think are the key
ingredients to to a good story I think
the best ingredient to a good story is
understanding what your audience wants
to hear okay cool and and and so and so
because I have so much listening
capability and so much empathy I'm able
to really understand what they want to
hear now what I think makes a great
storyteller is not a good one is
understanding what your audience wants
to hear and understanding what you
should tell them predicated on that and
allowing the authentic most high value
information get to them instead of
pandering or manipulating them come on
Tom forty four and six where you
okay four five and six all right I'll
come and I'll come to get you all right
what's up Instagram it's me Gary just
wants a hey
thank you from the bottom of my heart
for all the support and follow me on the
ground
better and that's and that's a game
changer really is that you know because
that's that's always been the case right
that's not the case for 99% of the bits
of storytelling right now so I think I
think I'm playing one big global game of
Jab Jab Jab right hook and that's why I
think I've think I've separated myself